you're you're the pupil I'm the teacher
mate okay we'll see can you read the
verse from the bowels of my mother have
he me mentioned me and said unto me thou
art my servant so now this means God has
said to Jesus Thou Art my servant oh
Israel correct well Jesus is not Israel
Jesus is Israel no Jesus
ISC Jacob is Israel okay keep reading
we're gonna I'm about to show so in
context it's talking about Jacob not
Israel it's not it's talking about the
Messiah who was identified as Israel it
can't can't be I've read four chapters
and so far this is not about Jesus
anyway let me continue well keep going
and now said the Lord that formed me
from the womb to be his servant to bring
ja Jacob again to him to bring who Jacob
wait I thought I thought that was Jacob
one second I thought that was Jacob well
look look can I can I make something
very very plain to you sure this this
Old Testament yeah it makes many many
mistakes errors
but it does H don't prolong this this
conversation all right all right all
right don't entertain it h I'm just
going to read this verse you went to so
6114 how much how much no mace forget
that God to be honest with you I mean
you know we have to hold our hands up me
and Hamza you know we're not masters of
the Arabic language our help came to
them at last we then saved whoever we
what you doing I'm stiring the pot sorry
what you doing that for because I'm
cooking you you saying that I'm going
around saying that the Quran is
100% uh Satan and fire oh did you say
that I never said that so who do you
believe came to Muhammad in the cave I
do believe that muham had a demonic
experience in the cave I don't believe
that everything in the Quran is
demonically like sourced so okay it's
fine so you don't believe the Quran is
sourced by Satan that no I believe that
there are some things that are demonic
and I believe that there's some things
that are just clearly man-made um so you
disagree with that and say that either
nor does David I don't really believe
you thinking believe in Islam I really
don't you really don't think I believe
in Islam not really why is that well you
don't know the Quran how do you know I
don't know the Quran I've spoken to you
you don't know the Quran what do you
mean I don't know the Quan you know the
Bible I know the Bible though you know
the Bible yeah I know it so I'm not
saying I believe that Jesus is
glorifying god um God the Father not at
negation of himself okay so how many
only true Gods can there there is one
true God and the one one is multi
personal the son the son happens to be
glorifying the father and according to
ramsy by the
way I'm say according to ramsy because
Ramsey agreed with me I have no problem
conceding for the sake of argument the
New Testament calls Jesus God ah very
good very good I'm to you he said the
New Testament said to you no I'm saying
I'm telling
you why you telling what someone else
believes I'm asking you so you disagree
withon that why you telling me what
someone else believes I'm asking you so
you disagree withon that notice this my
question testify or life was talked to
you kept bringing me up or what I say or
what I believe can you question I'm do
exactly what you did no I don't want you
the new says let me say it see you later
look at you you're a coward you're a
coward so like when Jesus says that he
was sent into the World by God as his
one and only son his unique son Can
someone say that and be a Muslim to
respond to you what language did Jesus
speak spoke Aramaic Hebrew and Greek so
in Aramaic could you use that for
endearment I don't know they called God
ABA in Aramaic that's father and so they
don't they don't oh yeah Jesus did it
too yeah but Bible's not an Aramaic well
no it has Aramaic words in it you didn't
know that no no no but where where does
Jesus use Aramaic ABA in the Bible Mark
14: 30 I think 6 he went prostrating
fell in his face and said ABA father ABA
poo if it be possible let this cut pass
from me that's Aramaic for father this
is the only word for father now when
Jesus says it obviously he's he I'm
sorry you said that's the only word in
Aramaic for father yes are you sure
about that yes so of say that again of
in Aramaic first so the word is Aba the
Aramaic term for father is Aba so that's
that's ABA right there man the live is
freezing up guys it's possible their
phone probably died now unfortunately
the conversation ended U Man's phone
died let's actually see what the word a
is so when we go over here to logos the
origins of ABA of Aramaic origin seen in
Daniel 5 2: 11 13- 18 ABA parallels the
Hebrew word of from where ABA or father
is derived the word of no it's not
Aramaic it's a Hebrew word it's not
Aramaic so again point is that Jesus
used the word ABA Jews use the word ABA
now watch this here some Scholars
consider it to be a colloquial term of
familiarity that a young child would
have used similar to how American
children use Papa or daddy the term
father is was a colloquial term used by
those who spoke Aramaic it's an Aramaic
word not a Hebrew word the word a in
Hebrew is it's different from from Aba
anyone who submit his will to the will
of God is a Muslim it's a little bit
more than that because like for example
if I were to say hey guys I submit my
will to God but my God is a statue you
guys wouldn't say that I'm a Muslim
right yeah which God talking about which
God you're not exactly right right
there's a specific concept of God that
you have to submit to and believe in in
order to be a Muslim we would agree
right yes right the god of Islam he
doesn't begin nor is he begotten he's
absolutely singular in his Essence right
he if in Islam somebody if somebody
believes in Allah yeah in every single
attribute but decided to call Allah
father is he disbelieving in Allah if he
says I believe in Allah everything his
his one everything but I'm going to call
him father does that commit sh does it
this is not the that Allah has used but
does it make him
a it's Innovation wouldn't it be yeah
it's
Innovation Innovation but it does not
make him a disbeliever yeah it doesn't
make so so can you be a Muslim can you
be a Muslim and say that Allah is your
father and you're his son can you you
can but you be it'll be an innovation
it'll be an
innovation tell God Logic the bastard
scum well there
go I missed that part that's right a
body armor
Jesus can't stab me without stabbing
your
butt I now the safest man in the world
is Allah a father in any sense is the
father in any sense yes now the issue is
the misinterpretation of the Old
Testament it's EAS a father in any sense
my friend the
misinterpretation for the New Testament
addressing God the creator of Jesus the
creator of the heavens is he a
father that's all I want to know yes he
doesn't have to answer either either
either you answer you take my answer as
it is it's not an answer though did we
get an answer today yet can you let him
answer you told me he was answer finish
his answer all right so you told we all
we all waiting for the answer okay is
Allah a father in any sense so is Allah
a
father you
got listen thank you we got a note break
there so no
answer no answer guys when we had a a
simple question how is Jesus a Muslim
what he did was is he went to the Bible
he went to the Bible where Jesus says
father let your will be done not my will
he said this shows he's a Muslim so I
said okay is Allah a father I can't get
an answer right now because he know
because he knows once he answers this
he's CED so please give just give us an
honest answer man we're waiting where
you going thank
you there it is
guys we busted your game right really if
you want to continue you just busted
Allah and Muhammad So when you say we
don't have any of the documents where we
can see or verify where Jesus said this
that's what you said because over the
centuries third fourth and fifth century
the Christians have corrupted their
scripture and that's why we cannot find
the true words of Jesus for example him
mentioning that a will come after him so
you just busted Muhammad where your
Quran says and Allah by the way because
Allah says that they had theel they had
the gospel that Jesus preached they had
it with them and in that in that wait
wait you saying that we don't of course
okay good so what so what is the inil
the injil is what God gave to is what
was that you're interrupting do you have
a problem of letting people speak I have
I have a problem of letting people lie
I'm trying to help you be on track you
just called me yes I do end of
discussion excuse me you just sh what
you can't say look I'm not interested in
speaking to someone who accused people
of lying but you you accuse me of having
memory problem of of of of of messing up
your words so so you can insult my
intelligence but I can't I can't say
that you're a liar anyone else a liar
capable to speak
is is there anybody else who's a Muslim
that could tell me where the heck can I
find Jesus saying off me all right take
here all right guys all right guys say
bye say
bye
[Music]
bye let me finish the point so by
necessity God is not first born
does that make sense he is God he is God
is firstborn yes he is all my that means
one minute all my got was immort yeah
absolutely I'm going to show you your
ignorance here the reason why you're
surprised by that is because you don't
know the Bible for example pry well okay
you know the Bible okay good how many
how many brothers did David have I don't
know how
manyal no I'm I'm going to show you how
it's consequential okay was David the
oldest middle or youngest I don't know
you don't know for
examp there was eight of them I'm going
show you I'm going to show you how there
was eight of them there was eight of
them David was the youngest now in Psalm
89 verse 27 God says about David you are
my first
born huh wait hold on a second David's
the youngest so how is it that David
could be the firstborn Mustafa good
point that's that shows that the Bible
is a bundle of contradiction in Exodus
in Exodus time now the spirit proceeds
from the father it does not mean the
spirit is a separate person from the
father does the father proceed from the
father no so then the spirit is not the
father the spirit is the father so the
father proceeds from the
father oh the function is crazy
I'm
Li guys we all understand this right the
spirit has different titles is one of
the titles of the spirit
father okay so the father is distinct
from the spirit correct
no give me get me out of here give me
give me I'm done I'm
done I want to leave I want to leave I
want to leave it's not
okaying I'm the Man to answer that
question all right so what is the we
confirm the NG but we say that we have
to to view it in the lens of the Quran
I'm not talking about confirmation right
now I'm just asking what it is what the
qur what conforms so what conforms with
the Quran is the inil what doesn't
conform with the Quran isn't the inil so
we have some of the some of the inil yes
so the inil we can find in our Bible yes
okay so why why is that but that's but
who but whoever disputed that so proving
Jesus is Muslim offering $2,200 to
whoever can he is I just donated money
in the Box okay there
I box everybody right now I'm not
debating I box for 2200 right now I'll
box you for 2200 right now youa beat me
do you
Bo let's box for 2200 how about that box
for 22 how aboutus
[Music]
theil that everything is created by his
word right the Heaven and the Earth came
into existence through his word right
now the Quran also says in chapter 4
verse uh 171 it says that Jesus is
Allah's word I'm human be God I don't
understand that like well do you believe
that God can do anything yes of course
do you believe that if God wanted to
that he could take on human form and
walk amongst us but he didn't I know I
know you he wanted to he God can do
everything you don't really have a
fundamental like uh you're not saying
that it's not possible you're saying
that you just don't believe it happened
the fact that in
Islam there's things like a pregnant
mother who loses her child right yeah
that child will go to heaven that mother
even if she
is you looked at me funny I did because
there a Hadi that doesn't guarantee even
babies to go to heaven like there's it's
in sahim Muslim in the book of Destiny
so this Sai Muslim 2662 see Aisha the
mother of the Believers said that
Allah's messenger peace be upon him was
called to lead a funeral prayer of a
child of the unsa okay so a child died
Allah's messenger there is happiness for
this child who is a bird from the birds
of paradise for it committed no sin nor
has he reached the age where one can't
commit sin now obviously that's like
yeah baby can't commit sin he didn't
reach the age he commit sin goes to
heaven straight away right
so this is what Muhammad responds with
um he said Aisha per Adventure like hold
on stop it it may be otherwise because
God created for Paradise those who are
fit for it while they were yet in their
father's lowings and created for hell
those who are to go to hell he created
them for hell while they were yet in
their father's loans so he's basically
saying it's possible that this baby this
child who died is going to is going to
hell because because Allah created them
for hell even if they didn't do anything
wrong say Christ said I am there's so
many scripture Matthew 19 17 he said why
callest thou me good there's none good
but one that is God he said to is Jesus
good I can call him good he said
[Music]
about look look look I'm I'm glad listen
give him a hand give him a hand I'm glad
I could teach I'm glad I could teach
listen I when you say they uh if Christ
created all things then you're saying
Jesus created Jesus specifically it says
that nothing that has been made right
but John 1:3 because the father gave
Christ the power to do that to do what
to create all things did he give him the
power to create himself he didn't have
to create himself because the father
this is this is so idiotic the father he
didn't have to when I'm saying they
didn't have to create himself I'm
talking about the most high you said
Jesus didn't have to create himself no
because the father created him well he
wait hold on it says that all things
that were made were made through him
except him where does it say that it
doesn't say he created himself where
does it say he created himself that's
that's a that must be swine that got to
be pork you cooking that got to be pork
precept give me a precept man give it a
precept welcome welcome today man we got
an in-house guest today man I got two
assassins with me on the stage we got
Shimon and himself and then we got one
of my newest friends here Jay Dyer in
the building how you guys doing fellas
well I'm pumping iron so get muskers I
look better than Jay that's what I'm
talking about I'm happy to be one of the
hashash one of the Assassins so that's
right that hashish baby so so listen
guys CP is that you yeah yeah give me a
minute we got the dizle himself David
wood in the house is going on yo what's
up boy we got a pate Prophet out here
hello what's up and then we also got
inspiring philosophy in the house first
time on the channel you're muted rookie
absolute
rookie and here we have it the man
himself hello hog shoot man I'm trying
to say again go I'm looking old I got a
shave and talk about you know being
under the weather I'm getting a little
sick so guys I'm not shocked today I
would be under the weather when it's
Muhammad's birthday and we're going to
expose Muhammad he's right there go I I
wrote down the wrong day so I thought it
was tomorrow but uh what's up Lana hello
focus in the Bible abouta age she was 3
years old and that was being approved by
the rabbis of the Jews can you show me
the verse that says Rebecca was I could
I could you also the links of the rabbis
speak I don't care about any rabbis or
anything I want to see those same rabbis
say that Jesus is not the Messiah do you
take what they say no you have seconds
show me the Bible verse or you're out of
here no I'm not going to show
know it you know this you know very good
right in Quran there is
no that Muhammad is correct you got the
verse yes I got two verses actually not
one beautiful she's about to show us two
verses that says that Rebecca was 3
years old I want him to open Deuteronomy
Deuteronomy she trying to get extra
credit wait wait wait a second yeah and
see what Jesus have said what does
Deuteronomy have to do with Rebecca just
let her cook man let her
L I'm G give you big screen L you got
big screen what does Deuteronomy got to
do with mother loving Rebecca man you
got big screen show
her go ahead go ahead Lana give it to us
go ahead Lana got big screen Lana look
at look look at your picture look at you
just pitiful just looking like a pitiful
tee just a sad te terrible l to you got
the verse
Oh yeah I got the verse all right there
we go what's the verse no I want to
speak to rob the liar no you're not GNA
you're not going to speak to Rob until
you show us the verse that says Rebecca
was three where's the verse because he's
lying so no
verse no we're not going to open that
again okay go ahead what do you want to
say to what do you want to say to Rob
sorry what do you want to say to Rob
well he right now saying this is dang
something happened would you like the
prophet Muhammad to have marriage
relations with your 9-year-old daughter
with your 9-year-old
daughter wait what hey Co CPS Co CPS
okay okay okay okay okay L please please
sorry say that again Lana would you
would you like your 9-year-old daughter
to have sexual relations with Muhammad
yes FBI open up oh my days okay okay
someone call CPS someone call CPS I feel
a d I think actually lock her off what's
wrong with
that we need to need to shut people down
with this this is such like a b no no no
stop stop stop stop why in the world
will we shut down a muslim with an
opinion like that disgusting but but yes
it's disgusting but it's Islam that's
true in a time where Islam is popular
when I say popular I mean it's
culturally popular to be sympathetic to
Islam right and it's and it's inop to
criticize it it's unpopular to call it
out to seem mean or intolerant towards
Muslim or the idea of Islam not real so
and but it's because they have painted
it in a picture of rainbows and cotton
candy exactly peace and love and
protection of women's rights and
protection children exactly
so why why in the world would we silence
a Muslim who is open and honest about
her religion and what teach I'm I'm
appreciating the respect that's going on
in this chat this is just better how we
communicate with each other just no
disrespecting sorry sorry can I just can
I no no no no no no no not yet not yet
not yet cuz I know you're going to hit
me with the question yeah yeah yeah but
listen no no listen no no no listen
listen listen
[Music]
no no but
I'm yeah
Che
huh why you talking
hey you good if somebody says uh Jesus
Is God is that acceptable to
you Isa
people have different perspectives so
that that's some people have their own
perspectives and they have their own
path and but but is it acceptable to you
or
[Music]
not um like like I said
I what do you think is the better
example following someone who was sinful
or following someone who never sinned
which one is the better example yeah
following someone who's not the siners
who hasn't committed
yes yeah how would one go about if they
like get you know connect with with God
do you believe do you believe that Jesus
is Lord yeah then I have to I have to
say yes yes then you're saved s yeah
thank you thank you will I ever be
forgiven I don't know man yeah what you
can do is so you just repeat after me
brother you say God God I am a sinner
I'm sinner I have sinned before you I
have sinned before you and I seek your
forgiveness and I seek your forgiveness
and I believe and I believe that you
Jesus that you Jesus are my Lord and
Savior are my Lord and Savior amen amen
who you serve my brother who you serving
who you serve choose today I Think Jesus
is the right way Amen to that bro do you
believe that Jesus is Lord yeah I
believe he is do you believe that he
died for your sins I believe he died for
our sins do you believe that he rose
again on the third day he did priz in
this day yeah amen then today celebrate
lift up your hands and glorify God
because today you are saved you are his
you are our brother in the Kingdom bro
what do I I mean how do I what do I do I
mean how can I you confess bro how do I
do that I'll just ask you this do you
believe that Christ is your lord I do do
you believe that he died for your sins
by crucifixion absolutely do you believe
that the father father raised him on the
third day from the dead for your sins I
do I do and do you trust in him and him
alone for your salvation only
him and then you're saved brother wow
wow I don't praise God praise God that's
not how I was expecting this to go
man so my question I guess to You Leon
would be why won't you believe what God
has revealed I don't know bro kind of
made sense now yeah who would you go
with all the prophets and the Messiah
that agree with each other that have the
same message or would you go with the
one who claims he's a prophet who
contradicts them who would you go with
if you're being honest Propet what are
you going to do I think I'm going to
become Christian bro how do I do it then
is there C or that Jesus is Lord yeah do
you believe that he died for your sins
and rose again on the third day yeah
then welcome to the family of Christ my
brother
[Applause]
[Music]
what's what's what's what's